avec ce problème il ya actuellement 1
20% de lit qui sont fermés faute de
personnel soignant dans les hôpitaux est
ce que le gouvernement est responsable
en tout cas il faut que le premier
ministre sache que sur l'ensemble de nos
départements de nos territoires nous
avons des problèmes en vendée par
exemple il me manque à peu près trente
deux équivalents temps plein pour
pouvoir assurer les urgences vous rendez
compte les urgences et ce qui se produit
en vendée se produit dans pratiquement
toute la france vous avez souligné le
chiffre lit sur cinq serait fermée
justement faute de moyens c'est monsieur
delfraissy qui est le président du
comité scientifique qui l'a révélé donc
je crois qu'il ya une urgence et on voit
bien parce que le silure de la santé ce
sera 12 milliards en 2022 on voit bien
que sans réforme si vous ajoutez
toujours plus d'argent public ça ne
marche pas c'est ça la réponse il faut
que le président de la république qui
fait le tour de france avec des chèques
emploi sachent que ce n'est pas avec
toujours plus de dépenses publiques
qu'on traite les problèmes il faut
réformer et l'hôpital il faut la dea
bureaucratisé et donc qu'est ce que
pourrait faire le sénat sur cette
question de l'hôpital et du système de
santé eh bien nous allons proposer mon
groupe est l'heure de faire justement
une commission d' enquête sur cette
question qui est trop grave parce
qu'elle concerne une affaire de santé
publique elle concerne chacun nos
compatriotes commission enquête qui va
être lancé qu'en cette commission
l'enquêtre sera apte et au tout début du
mois de décembre je l'ait déjà annoncé
hier en conférence des présidents ce
sera donc une commission d' enquête que
nous avons sur notre droite tirage et ce
sera important de faire toute la clarté
la vérité il s'agit pas de trouver un
coupable il s'agit de trouver des
solutions